ooh that one's our one Hey
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show attack
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by comedian Pete
Holmes you're gonna say hotter guests
he's the star and creator of HBO's hit
series crashing which enters its third
season this January you can catch him
and you made it weird with Pete Holmes
wherever you get your podcast and if all
that weren't enough he has a new comedy
special on the way called dirty clean
set to air on HBO December 15th I'm
still upset that you didn't say even
hotter guests and you're watching the
show with even hotter guest who is
properly hi I'm Sean hi I'm Sean Evans
and you're watching hot ones it's the
show with hot questions and even hotter
guests yeah sexy hot not like
temperately like sexual
[Music]
which I start from the right mm-hmm
start at the handle and we'll work out
with deactivates on the Titanic remember
one tight and fan one tight and fan at
Jagan that haircut being from Boston you
look like a racist does anyone
[Music]
it's not too spicy right no so I'm
crashing tell the semi-autobiographical
story of a struggling comedian and as I
understand it pulled some of your own
hard luck experiences as inspiration
when you think back on all the
humiliating things you had to endure as
an aspiring comic be it handing out
flyers in the rain or paying for your
own stage time is there a moment that
you describe as comedy rock-bottom you
know you're never completely immune to
it that's one of the things that makes
comedy super interesting like I did a
show in Philadelphia and I remember it
was like a bunch of arty fans and they
were just like not having me like it was
billed as like me and Artie Lange and
like all of Artie's fans came and none
of my fans and I look at me I'm not
Artie I come out and I'm just like have
you ever noticed rainbows I only have
four colors you know what I mean and
people are just like Vagan boo so you're
never immune what was your biggest
customer pet peeve when you were living
in Chicago and waiting tables at
Bennigan's between gigs that's I love
that question
it was the guy that would go I'll have a
water anyone else want water waters for
everybody and he doesn't realize that
there's nine people and I have to now
bring a tray of nine waters to one
[ __ ] who wanted water and eight
people who maybe didn't want water but
he wanted to make the joke of like I'll
buy a round of water like I hated that
that's from Texas shame on you Texas I
mean I'm just saying right for a state
known for kicking ass and spicing up
sauces to humble a little to humble for
me I'm gonna eat my words later when
this burns on the a-hole so I want to
ask you about your experience working
with the great Artie Lange who is a hot
ones guest that we talk about often was
he a guest or did he just wander in and
start eating away we started filming it
like a bear in the garden a little bit
of both you know he doesn't seem like
necessarily the number one choice they'd
have in casting when you're bearing the
responsibility of a huge HBO show yeah
it all connects no that was a that was a
big conversation we didn't write it with
him in mind I didn't really know Artie
before we did the show I mean looking
back he
you know he was a mess in the in the
beautiful Rd way I mean he was wearing
sunglasses inside his hair his pants
were falling down and he didn't say one
of the lines but he was so funny and
everybody else that came in sort of did
it by the book which by the anyone
watching that wants to audition that's
how you should do it Artie was just so
undeniably good at improvising and then
we realized that like he was the right
counterpoint whenever somebody's
starting comedy especially somebody is
doughy eyed and sweet as my character
and I was you need someone that's like
hey this isn't a joke like this career
eats people alive I will say humble
house it's a sleeper it's creeping up
yeah it's creeping up on me through the
backdoor of the hump no I don't mean my
butt I just mean like if it's a house
and it's humble they don't tell you
someone's creeping in the back door it
says next one is the smoked onions from
butterfly bakery it's a good that I
already feel sick
so in 2013 and 2014 you hosted a talk
show on TBS the Pete Holmes show which
is a mix of monologues interviews and
sketches yep now I thought that your
funniest [ __ ] might have been with
schoolboy q and your wall-e interview
and you made it weird is Loki one of the
best wrap interviews I've ever heard
really well thanks man do you think that
rappers and comedians share any of the
same genetic material they do
unfortunately rappers
sort of have this burden and I mean this
they have a burden to be cool all the
time like I watched my interviews with
Eminem and I'm just like it looks
exhausting that he has to be like
Detroit Detroit you know like it's like
he sometimes he just wants to be like
what's going on you guys you know what I
mean but he can he always has to be like
Haley Haley you know like he has to be
cool mm-hmm it's [ __ ] exhausting
schoolboy q seemed like he had an easier
time I think he was just high very very
stone
[Laughter]
[Music]
this one's called small axe peppers now
we're in the now we're in the ballpark
it's just real it's free hat day and the
hats lined with razor blades [ __ ] oh
it's good makes you miss the humbleness
perhaps of Texas I'm running back to the
humble house after this to cool down so
you're primarily known as a stand-up but
some viewers might be surprised to learn
that you're also an accomplished
cartoonist when you have a thought that
makes you laugh is there a mechanism
that goes off where you think maybe this
would be a better drawing than stand-up
bit I think that's one of the keys of
doing comedy actually is is honoring if
I can use the word honoring what a joke
or an idea wants to be so like if you
have an idea and you know it's a good
movie make it into a movie I've never
written the movie we'll try it now or
I've never been asked out to try it
instead of well I'm gonna force it into
you know my sketch team or something
well that's not what it wants to be when
you think of more everyman strips like
Garfield or Calvin and Hobbes is there a
comic that really stands out to you from
a comedians perspective
yeah the far side for sure I still think
the far side is hilarious and I love the
story Gary Larson sent to all his far
side cartoons like seven newspapers and
he didn't hear back so he drove I think
it was from like the Midwest to Chicago
to meet in person and he sold his first
strip like he got his first sort of job
then we came back his mailbox was filled
with rejection letters from all seven he
was like if he had waited one more day
he would have gotten all those rejection
letters and wouldn't have had the
courage to drive to Chicago so like the
mail like getting a slow no is why we
have the farside today but that was the
first like absurd thing that I had
really seen I loved Calvin and Hobbes
and I loved Garfield but the far side
did something nothing extra special
because it was dark nobody remembers
that it was dark you like that dark yeah
there's that there's that cartoon where
the farmers going out of the henhouse
with a basket full of eggs and a hen is
coming out of the house with a basket
full of babies that's hilarious
that's like a [ __ ] up joke the chicken
is gonna scramble the babies [ __ ] a
that ran next to roses Rose like that
was working on a different level louis
calientes what does that mean the spy
sees the hot ones
what it means mm-hmm are you sure about
that yes I think you're just committed
cuz you know I'm not gonna challenge you
but I think you are challenging man
you're right
Louis calientes I guess you're right
anyone speak Spanish nadie all right
Pete we have a recurring segment on our
so called explain that Graham we do a
deep dive on our guest Instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context so I'll bust out the laptop I'll
show you the picture and you just tell
me the bigger story is that sound good
so it's great all right laptop please
her shirt says pizza Oh does that go all
right it also includes the drink order
there's a whole theme we have here oh I
thought it was a crazy shirt but it says
Prosecco and pizza okay Pete Salem
reenactment yeah what's going on here
I was a reenactor in Salem Massachusetts
reenacting the first witch trial in
America the trial of Bridget bishop and
a show called cry innocent so anyway
we'd give the testimonies I still
remember though would give the actual
testimonies from 1692 and then the jury
of modern people with wrap around oak
leaves and disposable cameras would vote
as to whether or not she had committed
witchcraft
which was really fun that sounds like a
good time yeah it's where I met my first
wife she was the witch and I was the
judge and I sent her to burn not burn
but hang three times a day and take that
50
of gray that's some kinky [ __ ] right
there two drinks not vegans who drinks
not vegan
I almost hesitated posting that because
you know I I'm a vegan and vegans are
very serious about their veganism but I
was like no it's important to share the
moments that we're all full of [ __ ]
in fact I think vegans more full of [ __ ]
vegans should come forward because right
now it's such a Club of like you're
either in or you're out
yeah and as soon as you have like a
cookie there's eggs in it you're out we
also have to fess up the idea that most
of us even though I'm a vegan weren't
vegans for decades and decades and
decades so we have to have compassion
for people that eat meat or whatever and
then also I think we need to be honest
about the fact that sometimes you have a
couple beers yeah well it was a lot but
yep and then you eat a Shake Shack
burger and I really enjoyed it and does
that make me a bad person does that make
me not a vegan anymore I mean some
people would say absolutely I would say
no try to eat plants as much as you can
it's good for you and it's good for the
planet it's good for animals but if you
[ __ ] up don't be embarrassed that's what
we're all doing we're all just tripping
and getting up and talking about it
tripping and getting up and talking
about it that's what life is a sum
that's oh do mm-hmm or Hindi one of the
other why am I asking a snowstorm of a
man is it Hindi or do like talking to an
H&R block okay all righty then hilarious
well done as someone who grew up
spending hours at the arcade playing
Street Fighter what blows your mind most
you are a gentle man Thank You P that's
very sweet you've done all this research
it's really kind of you most people
don't do this deep dive yes Street
Fighter 2 as someone who writes for TV
is there a game that really nails it
from plotline story development angle to
you
well I do think Red Dead does a really
good job of that a lot of the younger I
got him old a lot of the younger players
were like complaining that the game it
kind of opens in a linear way and
they're like I hate it and I was like
but it's bonding it with the characters
that's how I know I'm older like now you
have an emotional tide of Dutch so when
Dutch gets this or this you really want
to save them you know like so I'm that
game is made for 40 year olds 40 year
old dudes and I'm that I'm that man I
touched my nose and my nose is burning
have you done that before yeah I gotta
be careful around your face yeah face
and eyes yep
all right this is called Colley's
firewater mm-hmm is that okay that
that's Native American like firewater
everything's racist if you look hard
enough
all right firewater got firewater [ __ ]
you
yeah firewater is one of those [ __ ]
yourself ones does it say that yeah it
says right here go [ __ ] we're in [ __ ]
yourself territory going forward its
bordering on horrible so one of the
funniest scenes in crashing is when
you're at one of those deli buffets
stuffing as much food as you possibly
can into a container and I'm curious
besides the classic slice what are some
of the foundational meals of a
struggling comedian what you would do is
you'd eat as little as you could during
the day to save money then when you got
to the club you order the chicken
fingers or whatever the appetizer that
was free for the comedians you would
order that where do rich comedians eat
whoo that one's a hot one
hey there's your promo where did rich
comedians eat I've been to dinner with
jad many times and jet is certainly a
well well off he's well off and he eats
Craig's that's why rich comedians eat
there's always paparazzi people waiting
out front to see your post pork chop
face sell it to the media
there's a lot of similarities between
the come up for comedians and rappers
but I think the difference is you know
you grind it out you make it and then a
rapper I'll start talking about the
lobster that he eats and the champagne
that he drinks yeah Shawn you're
brilliant
that's right but you don't really hear
that coming from I don't finish everyone
knows what you men don't finish the
point when I get it they got it why is
that honestly that's such a good
observation I you can't say certain
things and lose your every person Asst I
still think Bill burr buys his own
groceries but when you go and see like
Seinfeld or whatever and he's one of my
favorites he's just like you know we're
near the cab it's like Jerry you have an
SUV waiting behind the SUV that's
picking you up in case that SUV has an
aroma you don't like you know do you
mean like you you're out but we don't
want to hear about that
if you talked about that we would we
would back away it's like John Mayer
right I think so we're the young girls
go and see John Mayer it was a cool it's
me he's [ __ ] a different one of you
every night like how can you buy into
this perso the growth this persona that
just like I just want to write poetry
you know he wants to [ __ ] three of you
after the show and with comedians like
John Mulaney sells out Radio City six
times he's doing okay and then and then
you know he's one of my best friends one
of my favorite comedians we still kind
of go along with the lie if he's just
like and Delta charges for an extra bag
it's like dude you could buy the plane
what's one yeah you knew you knew what
you did now you know what you gave me
you feel me do bomb this is not the bomb
no it's not it's more like a bomb
something that's dead bomb
let me mansplain this to you fool me
usually means that it's excellent like
that hansen contact was de bomb give me
their email address i have a couple
things i want to send them one is a
virus to take down their whole company
why would you eat that so in addition to
your Batman character you've racked up
tens of millions of online views with
the Solaris sketch series in which you
play Professor X firing various members
of the x-men having worked your way
through most of the roster which x-men
do you think is actually the most
expendable Wolverine
[ __ ] [ __ ] it get him out of here he's a
bar fight hero he is the coolest I'm not
saying he's not the coolest he's
worthless let's say your free gyros are
supposed to save us from like a
meteorite coming towards ear Wolverine
is just gonna be like it's closer like
he'll just smell it coming
rogue she can do something let's say you
were being held captive by a serial
killer in a storage container somewhere
and you can only call one super hero to
save you who would you have the most
confidence in Superman
that's why Superman sucks tip to perfect
this movie suck ass
they suck my ass all day where do I
relate where do I relate to this
Superman just like I saw through the
walls you forget he has so many powers I
have wind breath [ __ ] you pick one I
have ice breath that's like a 1950's
[ __ ] character which superhero do
you think would have the best Instagram
feed what's the real main Stamos one you
know I'm talking about you know a
mystique yeah mystique oh then she
became Jennifer Lawrence later that was
just what a nightmare there's Batman the
most relatable to you yes getting out
there you shoot him he bleeds economy
bleeds it can die his parents are dead
great they're all dead parent people
that you can't be a superhero with with
living parents I think yeah probably
there's some sort of trauma that has to
fuel that energy you need trauma and you
also need someone no one there to be
like get that cape off cause your mom's
driving gloves
shut up they're a dime a bat get that
belt off what you have a yellow belt on
I made it has advil in it and the dad
leaves this is hard
I don't want to eat it all right for no
reason you don't even try to talk me
into it I just kept okay all right I
knew I didn't have to yeah I know we
like playing around mm-hmm what we're
doing here yep we're in these space
suits that expire we should you know
feeding weird [ __ ] just to see what it's
like this is also how I get people to
try ecstasy really well yeah I'm a drug
dealer all right I came on your YouTube
showed up
let me let myself out of the back no
I've never done it have you yeah mm-hmm
Tables attorney but speaking of you
discuss spirituality quite a bit on your
podcast I've heard you described as
someone who seeks enlightenment almost
to a fault have you ever had a religious
experience while on mushrooms or LSD or
anything like yeah yeah absolutely
reza aslan who was the professor of
religious studies at Harvard for a while
and then he wrote the book zealot and he
read the book God he came on my podcast
and he said that you can trace every
major religion back to the use of
psychedelic clans and really it's not a
surprise every one of them is telling
you something I don't think there's
anything more exciting than taking a
psychedelic plant something that people
have been taking for millennia and
merging with those thoughts honestly you
can get there through a lot of
experiences that get you out of your
brain sex music you have that moment
where you realize that it's not about
knowing something it's about becoming
something and it's not about learning
something it's about forgetting
everything that you've learned and I
know this all sounds very trite but that
really is what it is and sometimes that
sounds it makes more sense to me than
other times right now I'm saying it I
sort of feel on the outside of the idea
but there are times that I've been on
the inside of it so I can say from
experience that it's true and most of
those experiences we're on mushrooms
[Music]
everything I just said would make more
sense if you guys were all smoking dabs
it's funny that you say that Pete we are
doing dabs
this is the last dab we call it the last
dab because it's tradition around here
to put a little extra on the last wing
you don't have to if you don't want to
did while they do it did while we do
this while I did do this while I did dab
I think I got it
[Music]
all right cheers Cheers what a trip it's
been Pete what a wild trip it's been
[Music]
sike I'm just kidding I Pete Holmes
we've talked about your HBO series we've
talked about your cartoons and we've
talked about your love of video games
but one thing we haven't touched on or
your comedy roots and improv before this
siren song of stand-up brought you to
the stage so as we close it out I want
to play a little game called what would
it be if have you ever heard of that
nope
what would it be if the rules are simple
I'll point to a hot sauce and you say
what it would be if it were a flower
what it would be if it were a movie what
it would be if whenever I say and we can
start at the classic the classic if it
were a pop star what would it be
Miley Cyrus but Hannah Montana humble
house if it were a Judd Apatow movie I
think that would be trainwreck spicy
poster surprisingly heartfelt and gentle
Lowe's calientes if it were a woman the
woman from Modern Family Sofia Vergara
no no the child so funny no no the child
was the bomb if it were a city I mean
the lost city of Atlantis but the waters
fire xrs co if it were a historical
figure I mean it's got Medusa in the
bottle but I'm gonna say Ernest
Hemingway and finally the last dab for a
life philosophy penny saved is it Holmes
I am leaking and look at you leaking but
for a good cause because you just took
down ten scorching hot vegan chicken
wings he checked and now there's nothing
left to do but roll out the red carpet
for you Pete Holmes this camera this
camera or this camera let the people
know what you have going on in your life
Oh God well I have diarrhea coming up in
about 20 minutes
if you guys want tickets there's only
one seat
December 15th is my special dirty clean
on HBO and then January kind of touch my
I judge you almost made it Pete
you almost made it kind of feels good
like icy hot and I can see a color I've
never seen before crashing season 3
premieres in January the trailer is
available now on your tube that's what
they call me or two and please listen to
you made it weird good job good job I
can't open it
yeah I'm just kidding you're good man
good empathy did you have fun Pete that
was it no yeah I had a great time thank
you hey what's going on spice Lords this
is Sean Evans checking in by his
lonesome and you know what that means
it's time for another hot sauce PSA and
for two years we've been working on
making the perfect entry level sauce
something that's good for everyone
number one on our board and now it is
finally here the classic is our
contemporary twist on the original
vinegar-based sauces throughout American
history with chili de arbol peppers and
garlic for that perfect balance as
always people who order the hot ones
monthly subscription box got it first
but now it's available for everyone heat
miss calm heat miss calm to pick up the
classic the classic it's for the people
[Music]